Transcription: Elisabeth Buffard
Relecteur: eric vautier
Lorsque nous prononçons
le mot « histoire »…
D’ailleurs, dites-le pour voir !
Public : Histoire !
Super !
Maintenant, je voudrais
que vous pensiez deux secondes
à l’image que vous avez eue en tête
quand vous avez prononcé ce mot.
Je suis presque sûr
qu’il y en a parmi vous
qui ont directement eu l’image
de leur cours de collège ou de lycée,
de leurs livres qui pesaient une tonne
autant dans leur sac
que dans leur mémoire,
et qui, il faut bien le dire,
étaient loin de tous nous parler.
Ce n’est absolument pas
ce dont il est question ici.
Ici, il est question de s’imprégner,
non pas de l’histoire, mais des histoires,
car elles sont une infinité et elles ont
toutes quelque chose à nous offrir.
Si vous le voulez bien,
durant les quelques minutes
que nous avons à passer ensemble ce soir,
j’aimerais vous donner
ne serait-ce qu’une idée
de tout ce que les histoires
ont à nous donner.
Parce qu’il faut bien
commencer quelque part,
je voudrais vous parler
d’une des premières histoires
qu’on nous a tous racontée,
peu importe notre âge : la fable.
Vous vous souvenez des fables,
du « Corbeau et le Renard »,
de La Fontaine, tout ça ? Ça vous parle ?
Eh bien, La Fontaine,
depuis son 17ᵉ siècle,
a appris aux enfants que nous étions
à se méfier des flatteurs,
comprendre la vraie valeur du travail
ou encore qu’on a toujours besoin
d’un plus petit que soi.
En somme,
il nous a donné des enseignements,
des valeurs et des idées,
utiles pour toute une vie.
Et ça, il l’a fait
en nous racontant des histoires.
Le voilà, le cœur de mon idée
et le sens de ma passion.
L’histoire ou les histoires,
à l’instar des fables de La Fontaine,
ont des milliers de choses à nous offrir.
En premier lieu, elles nous offrent
sur un plateau d’argent
les erreurs du passé.
Oui, je sais très bien ce qu’on peut dire,
que ce sont les erreurs de grands hommes
aux conséquences sans commune mesure
avec celles que nous pourrions commettre.
C’est vrai.
Mais au même titre
que vous ne serez jamais
Napoléon Bonaparte
guidant ce qui lui reste de troupes
après sa défaite en Russie,
vous ne serez jamais Maître Corbeau,
tenant en son bec un fromage.
Et pourtant rien ne vous a empêché
de retenir la leçon de Maître Corbeau,
de vous mettre à sa place
quand vous étiez petit.
Ce que je veux vous dire,
c’est qu’il faut faire voler en éclats
cette barrière qui oppose
hier et aujourd’hui
ou les grands hommes des plus modestes.
Parce que cette barrière,
elle est uniquement dans nos esprits,
alors que l’histoire, elle,
elle est omniprésente.
L’omniprésence de l’histoire,
on peut en parler.
Je suis sûr qu’il y en a parmi vous,
même une bonne partie,
qui, pour venir ici ce soir,
ont réglé leur GPS
sur le 14 avenue Saint-Laurent
au 91 400 Orsay.
Vous vous êtes donc guidés
grâce à une technologie
qui n’aurait jamais vu le jour
sans la guerre froide.
Cette même technologie identifiant
une rue numérotée selon
un système inventé par Napoléon
et qui porte le nom
d’un martyr romain mort en 258.
Vous voyez tout ce qu’une simple adresse
peut nous apporter comme histoire
religieuse, technologique
et administrative de notre pays,
et même du monde de manière générale,
pour peu qu’on laisse notre esprit
s’adonner à sa propre curiosité.
Et notre curiosité,
si on la laisse courir,
si nous ne lui permettons pas
de s’essouffler,
nous découvrons encore
autre chose à l’histoire.
Mais cette fois-ci,
ce n’est pas un enseignement,
c’est une vertu, un œil nouveau
sur tout ce qui nous entoure.
La connaissance de l’histoire
nous permet de voir
une deuxième dimension
à ce que nous trouvons beau
et de trouver de la beauté
à ce qui en est de prime abord dépourvu.
Mais là, ça ne vous parle pas,
ce que je vous dis.
Vous ne vous y retrouvez pas.
Donc ce que je vais faire,
c’est à mon tour
vous raconter une histoire,
une histoire toute bête,
d’une visite au musée d’Orsay
avec ma copine.
On se baladait simplement
dans l’allée principale,
celle avec toutes les sculptures
néoclassiques.
On regardait un peu toutes les statues.
Quand soudain, mon regard a été
comme happé par l’une d’elles
qui me paraissait vraiment familière.
Cette statue, c’était
le « David et Goliath » d’Antonin Mercier.
Celle-là, là.
Et là où mon amoureuse voyait
une sculpture à la beauté indiscutable -
elle avait raison -
moi, je voyais un objet d’émerveillement
parce que je connaissais
l’histoire de David et Goliath.
Certains d’entre vous, à mon avis,
la connaissent aussi.
Mais je vais faire un très rapide résumé.
J’ai donc commencé à lui raconter,
avec une joie immense et une pointe
d’orgueil absolument pas dissimulée,
(Rires)
que Goliath était un soldat de l’armée
philistine dans l’Ancien Testament,
aux proportions gargantuesques,
qui avait pour mission
de soumettre les peuplades juives
de la vallée des Térébinthes.
Et ce géant appela l’armée d’Israël
à lui envoyer un soldat
qui serait capable
de le vaincre en combat singulier.
Il réitéra son appel pendant 40 jours
et au bout du 40e jour,
David, un adolescent,
fils de berger, un peu frêle,
répondit à l’appel de Goliath.
Il se présenta devant lui,
muni de sa fronde,
et lui lança une pierre
qui se logea en plein milieu
du front du géant
et l’abattit d’un coup.
Pendant que je racontais ça,
je voyais les gens autour de moi
ralentir la cadence de leurs pas,
prêter une oreille discrète
à ce que je racontais,
et même lorsque j’eus fini,
allaient regarder l’entaille
sur le front de Goliath,
juste ici.
Et c’est à ce moment-là
que je l’ai ressenti.
Le plus grand plaisir que l’histoire
puisse nous apporter, celui de raconter.
Ce plaisir sans lequel je ne serai pas là,
devant vous, simplement,
et sans lequel
l’histoire n’existerait pas d’ailleurs.
Ce plaisir intense
de me dire que ce jour-là,
les gens autour de moi
n’ont pas juste regardé une statue,
l’ont trouvée jolie
puis en ont regardé une autre.
Non ! Ils sont ressortis avec
un petit morceau d’histoire,
un peu comme s’ils avaient volé
un infime fragment de cette statue.
Et même peut-être qu’ils sont ressortis
avec une étincelle de curiosité,
leur disant de regarder
un peu autour d’eux,
de comprendre l’histoire autour d’eux.
Mais là, je me fais peut-être
des illusions.
Mais bon, si après ce que je viens
de vous raconter,
David et Goliath,
les fables de La Fontaine,
Napoléon, tout ça,
même si pour vous, l’histoire, c’est
encore quelque chose d’un peu abstrait,
d’un peu emmêlé, qui appartient vraiment,
définitivement aux salles de classe,
j’aimerais vous montrer que vous portez
[inaudible]
un chapitre de l’histoire de l’humanité -
pourquoi pas ? -
un chapitre de l’histoire de France,
si on veut,
mais elle est avant tout un chapitre
de l’histoire de votre famille.
D’ailleurs votre famille,
du moins votre nom de famille,
vous savez d’où il vient ?
Bon, si vous vous appelez Lemaire,
Leroux, Legrand ou Chevalier,
vous savez sans doute
d’où vient votre famille
et qui étaient vos ancêtres.
Mais si j’ai un peu de chance,
il y a des Lefèvre dans cette salle.
Non ?
Dommage.
Mais bref, vous connaissez sûrement
au moins tout un Lefèvre, quelqu’un ici ?
Ah, j’ai quelqu’un, super !
Eh bien, votre ami, la personne
que je n’ai pas très bien identifiée,
ne sait sûrement pas que son nom vient
du latin faber qui veut dire fabriquer,
qu’il a donné le mot orfèvre
et qu’il désignait
au Moyen-Âge un forgeron.
Est-ce qu’il y a des Martin
dans la salle ?
Oui ! Le nom le plus donné en France,
je ne prenais pas énormément
de risques sur celui-là.
Votre nom vient, lui, du dieu Mars.
C’est une déformation, c’est pour ça
que martien a un T, comme Martin.
Donc vous venez aussi
du Dieu de la guerre.
Là, on parle de noms de famille,
ça me rappelle quelqu’un.
J’avais un professeur de câblage au lycée,
Monsieur Malinowski,
qui refusait catégoriquement
de nous appeler par nos prénoms.
Parce que, selon lui, le nom de famille
[inaudible]
et qu’on devait en être fier.
Monsieur Malinowski avait raison.
Il avait tellement raison
qu’il a dit en une phrase
ce qui m’a pris pas loin de deux semaines
à écrire et dix minutes à vous dire.
Mais quand on y pense,
dix minutes, c’est si peu.
Ce n’est rien !
C’est absolument insuffisant
à qui que ce soit
pour parler de sa passion.
Une passion,
ça se raconte tout au long d’une vie,
au fil de ce qu’on lit, voit, apprend,
des gens que l’on rencontre.
Parce que oui, pour moi, l’histoire,
et même la passion de manière générale,
c’est avant tout des rencontres,
des rencontres avec des personnalités,
avec d’autres passionnés
qui vous donnent un nouveau regard
sur votre passion
ou qui même vous en donnent
une toute nouvelle.
Eh bien, j’espère
que cette soirée,
ça a été pour vous une rencontre,
une rencontre qui vous a permis
de vouloir ouvrir les yeux,
qui vous a donné cette curiosité,
qui vous a donné envie de regarder
l’histoire et le beau qu’elle suscite
tout autour de vous.
Et si la prochaine fois que vous passez
dans une rue Sainte-Geneviève
ou vous vous arrêtez
à la station de métro Duroc,
vous vous dites :
« Mais qui était Sainte-Geneviève ? »
ou « Qu’est-ce qu’a
bien pu faire Duroc ? »,
et allez chercher la réponse,
alors les quelques minutes que
nous avons passées ensemble ce soir
auront vraiment été utiles
et auront vraiment transmis ce que
signifiait pour moi le mot « passion ».
Je vous remercie infiniment
et vous souhaite une excellente soirée.
(Applaudissements)